take a second and scope out your
competition what monetization methods do
they implement most often in your
searching have you also found any hidden
competitors and by hidden we mean
companies that might be fighting on the
same budget as you but offering a
different service this might require you
to get a little bit creative in your
search terms may be getting very
specific or drilling down to page two or
three of the results but seeing what
people in the same monetary class are
doing to monetize is a great way to get
ideas for your own product when
researching your competitors take a
moment and jot down the pros and cons to
their approaches to monetization you can
do this using the provided boxes